ok prendiamo il pannolino
ma è sul piano di sopra
benvenuti solita storia anche se questa
volta non siamo alle 3 di notte e oggi
giocheremo gioco in cui dobbiamo fare i
baby sitter ma questo bambino è molto
strana un pò di paura ma se questo video
raggiungere i 20 mila mi piace faremo i
baby sitter nuovamente dei bambini
inquietanti ma alle 3 di notte e quindi
mi raccomando lasciato bel mi piace
questo gioco fa un pochino di paura
penso quindi per tenervi pronti farebbe
dipankar non mettetevi comodi e iniziamo
subito a fare i baby sitter vediamo se
ce la caviamo cominciamo eccolo è laggiù
il bambino lo vedete allora dài non
sembra troppo in mostra nyt è perché ha
fame
vedi c'e scritto meglio mangiare al
bambino prendi la bottiglia dal frigo e
non è troppo inquietante voi cosa ne
pensate a un po gli occhi estranei si
vede
ho paura che fa qualcosa mandrano ecco
la pagina più bella questa cucina allora
devo prendere una bottiglia nel frigo e
adesso dice dai la bottiglia al bambino
vediamo un po che volevo solo mangiati
dai non è troppo inquietante quello che
non farà qualcosa di strano
infatti c'è scritto porta il bambino al
tavolo per cambiarlo devo cambiare il
pannolino questione
sta diventando un po inquietante non so
perché l'ho aggiornato devo prendere
cosa prendi la mutanda questo del
pannolino è sparito il bambino ei ma
come hai fatto spostarti da solo c'è
qualcosa di strano fino a 600 bambino mi
raccomando arrivare qua
bravo aiuto come mi guarda con quegli
occhi
ok e meno male
ho quindi evito di cambiate ora disse di
portarlo a letto ma sbaglio o è
diventato più magra tipo sta diventando
sempre più inquietante quei guanti
vertice lo avevo anche prima li ho
notati solo adesso e servono cui quanti
verdi leggio tratte dalla sua parte ok
come mostrano queste chiuse la sua
cameretta casina bene non è quel letto
scritto di spegnere le luci ok ciao ma
smettila ripararmi con quegli occhi
inquietanti ma lo sappiamo che nei porti
ok luci spente e lo tiro porta c'è
scritto ciao io scappo dio sono
dimenticato di dirvi come si chiama
questo già toccato ero troppo distratta
dal bambino si chiama the baby in yellow
che con di regia il bambino in giallo
non so perché ha questo nome strano
corsa perché se la maglietta gialla blu
si dice di guardare la tv ok
speriamo non succeda qualcosa di strano
stiamo per adottare il bambino piange
vuoi andare dal bambino per calmare il
bambino ma sembrava che la piazza la
porta il bambino si pensa venture aiuto
non equa luce più bambino dov'è finito
e forse al piano di sotto nella lui che
è sceso faccia scendere da solo
buonasera
ok ma disse di riportare una lettera ho
nella testa rhythm e un po meno i
militanti vedercelo maglietta gialla
forse per quello scopriamo che poi si
trasforma tutto in giallo diventa giallo
però c'è qualcosa di strano in questo
bambino ma io voto errore dobbiamo
prenderlo quale gli occhi puoi andare
dopo anche 10 diceva di spegnere la luce
ok secondo me si arrabbia tantissimo
questo bonetti addio io me ne vado
si è aperto una porta che ha aperto la
porta
lo dice di andare aiuto a dio dice di
andare a portare la tv non ha riaperto
la porta
dunque mtv come non voglio carrellati
come di allargamento fuoco la tv ok
notte numero 2 dice guarda guarda non è
divertente è la baby sitter dice che ho
detto di non ti ho detto che non dovevi
farlo che conta comunque ci siamo
sopravvissuti alla notte numero uno il
bambino è ancora in vita e anche noi
quindi siamo stati lì brachetti che mi
avete fatto e cosa dobbiamo fare dice
prendi la bottiglia dal frigo proprio
bambino
non so perché ho l'impressione che mi
stai guardando con quegli occhi
giganteschi e ramenzoni è sul tavolo
certo fino a cucina
devo prendere la bottiglia o dal freddo
eccola qui sono andate via le luci
ok accendi la luce in cui vivo dalla
bottiglia al bambino come hai fatto a
trento trasportarti soprattutto a me
perché io scopro prima non c'era guarda
non smette di fissarmi diciamo io al
ballerino dargli da mangiare quando gli
deve baciare supeficie ops è caduto
scusa lo ha fatto cadere io è infatti no
perché non posso più prenderlo youth è
andato ho sentito che si spostava no
ancora lì ma che lo devi cambiare
nuovamente che i fari per bocca vi
raccomando eh non scappare
lei messo un po in bilico però aveva
offrire che gamestop non vi dirò che
prendiamo il pannolino perché così sopra
come hai fatto
ora devo andare a prenderla of a questa
stanza non l'avevo vista le mani ei loro
usi per i bambini talismani
ok se qualcosa di strano ok abbiamo
ripreso il pannolone pannolino prima che
si arrabbi e mi faccio volare
quindi sì è vero che è stato facile dice
di portarlo a letto nuovamente devi
dormire non mi guardate cosa è successo
se teletrasportato rivista ok può
succedere magari che all'improvviso si
spengono le luci e bambino frottole
dall'altra parte dell'avanzo dai vai a
dormire
vai da armi e tiro bene mi raccomando
ora devo spegnere la luce addio poi a
curarlo tv questa tv non c'è niente
vabbè cosa succede
magari abbiamo finito anche il capitolo
due note numero 3 il bambino dice buona
no no la baby sitter cioè io dico buona
notte il bambino dice ti mostrerò i miei
sogni aiuto devo andare a prenderlo ma
finisce proprio guardare la tv guarda è
arrabbiato non lo so perché preoccupato
niente di pagare circa via della seta
viaggiare perché sei arrabbiato ok
chiudi la porta magari potete spegnere
pure lupus e verona beh lasciamo gli la
luce accesa ma sono presentati solo di
calmarlo dai
poverina una pianta e fa paura guerra
che papa voleva solo essere rassicurato
chiudiamo la porta a dice cerca qualcosa
da mangiare
che cosa c'è scritto fini ritmi che vuol
dire nutrimi david a mangiare ma io lo
sapevo che c'era qualcosa di strano come
ha fatto fare queste cose è un po
indemoniato c'è scritto dargli da
mangiare you mons cioè io sarei il
vostro è no il bambino ma noi dobbiamo
fare un tosto col formaggio detto si
prova a trovare anche la cucina dove
devo andare
allora il foro non si apre come faccio a
prendere qualcosa da vangeli prende il
pane là dentro corridoio un passaggio
segreto
no se sono i ripiani nel frigo sia
allungato il frigorifero macchinoso
lento nel frigo e fatto il bambino mi ha
chiesto dentro il frigo uscire la prova
ad uscire che successo come abbiamo
fatto ad uscire ma poi aroma in cucina
se vuoi arrivare dalla passo tutta la
causa di gas propano basta lo score zone
vitali
oddio guarda che faccio pronto e sara
superata
ok è tornato normale dice di cambiarlo
nuovamente senti ma non è che puoi
cancellare questa scritta non puoi non
cambia volo continuano a guardarlo in
modo strano
[Musica]
la prima porta a porta
le altre porte neanch'io fosse un chi ha
paura
ok questo torino riprende gruppo brand
rai a torino nel compimento con di voto
[Musica]
ok ok hanno preso speriamo che questo lo
ritrasformi norme però qua a ok ho letto
ha detto non mi fa più paura mi fa pena
dai ore ti porta a dormire ma non pare
che questi scherzetti ma si è portato a
letto da uomo io non voglio andare là
dentro
guarda c'è l'ombra mette il bambino
forse deve riprendere a no non dovete
fare il tris ancora sciolto non fosse
pesca un po ma per che cosa farà quel il
tentacolo tipo il talismano non esulta
liz mano non posso più prenderlo come
faccio a che paura
devo per forza andare dal ha delusi non
funziona o no lo so che deve stendere
dal bambino automatizzato da lui
ciao
buonanotte e vi un complicato gioco
capitassero pauroso divertente come
l'adrenalico diteci voi cosa ne pensate
di questo gioco per mera o appunto super
divertente anche se faccio un po di
paura quando il bambino si trasformò
loro fantastico la sete un bel bps sono
servizi che proviamo altri giochi del
genere e ora vi lasciamo cocco counter
lines cliccare per vedere i nostri altri
video cliccate su quella notte